hey I was gonna press my name's
look at me doesn't it look nice I think
it looks very nice there's clubs now in
the game which means you can you can
join clubs and [ __ ]
that's pretty cool there it is look at
those cucumber titties just chillin
there's like way more people in school
now look at that look at look they never
end oh my god get in we're gonna kill
them all all right we're gonna mow your
mall later well let's first check out
some things some additions to the video
games I think that's what's so cool
about this game is that it keeps getting
updated okay where am i okay yeah here's
a new club the occult Club where people
read books in a circle I always wanted
to join a club they seemed really fun we
don't really have them in school all
right well I'm just gonna follow these
random people as it's my class
oh god I'm late for classes sis my class
how - mine class how - mine class how
did [ __ ] I'm late but where the [ __ ] is
my class oh here it is no that's a Judo
Club I hear this oh [ __ ] what the well
that went [ __ ] that girl's hair is
[ __ ] amazing Wow
oh they locked the school now during the
day
Jesus Oh what the mace I didn't mean to
go in here
Oh porn awesome look how fast I run
track Jesus Christ my panties are
falling off Oh what is this this is the
girls club oh this is adorable
look at this somebody awesome new stuff
okay here see a cult plot this is the
cult club leader so we're gonna ask her
to join actually what yes I do want to
join the club of people who are
constipated wait I don't have to drink
the blood of senpai or anything well
that's disappointing
oh well we did it is there any club
activities besides talking like you
really have to take a [ __ ] okay let's do
the club activity we're going to attempt
that sounds good regular Monday the [ __ ]
is this their call club attempts to
summon a demon they do not succeed this
[ __ ] - future [ __ ] scheme is weirder and
weirder man let's look at that porn we
found earlier oh mama mia pizzeria I got
that girl's chest Oh God
I don't know about that okay so first
let's quit the damn emo club okay so
here's the yuta fun okay we're joining
the euro club
so you domine x' that you can beat
people like you are less likely for
people to kick your ass
which i think is a good thing yes yes
excellent let's begin
that's it you look at that [ __ ] Kel in
it kellen it yonder a chen and there we
go that's another day wasted in complete
bowl of shame all right let's begin
popping those [ __ ] up Jesus Christ
calm down you're fine you're dead
oh god don't fight me oh [ __ ] I [ __ ]
her up because I was Oh God let's but oh
god a [ __ ] them all up because I'm in
the Judo Club [ __ ] one shot these
hoes yes can I punch people now this is
phase of the anime one punish man let's
see if we can one punch people
one punch senpai I don't look at me I'm
bald but you can punch people one punch
one punch
don't worry about one punch wouldn't
stab you and Derek ten something such
[ __ ] everyone well this music is so
fitting where are you running
what are you running
damage got away [ __ ] you never mind you
just have to press control okay here we
go
one pot Jesus Christ she flew to the
other side Oh oh my god I gotta make my
boobs a little bigger fabrica fix me
daddy oh oh it's so pretty out here
oh god that senpai she can't see me ball
fine
oh [ __ ] oh yes what are you going mate
Oh teacher officially best game of all
time best game what is he trying to do
Oh tragedy hi press I'm gonna have to
end that episode that that was a lot of
a lot of a lot of a lot of fun I love
this game
check out the development don't email
him stupid questions
thank you for watching leave a like if
you one more you know some generic
simulator and that's it for me for now
as always stay awesome rest oh nice this
is how you crawl baby really great boob
physics I got a you gotta appreciate
that it takes a lot of time and effort
to put that [ __ ] in there